See you soon.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Before we get started,
let's do a revision very quickly.
How many what how many points of
criteria
for someone to be obligated to fast for
the month of Ramadan?
The conditions
six
five
six for females right let's list them
meaning of the age of puberty
which means a resident
and healthy enough to fast and for
females the addition
is what
she is not in state of menration or
postpartum bleeding. What is the this is
a little quiz here. What is the
what is the parameters
for sanity? How do we distinguish sane?
Huh?
[Arabic recitation]
okay. Is able to have a distinguished
focused intention. Able to hold an
intention, a a coherent intention. Okay.
Very good so far. How many pillars for
fasting?
two pillars. Number one,
intention. Number two,
abstaining from anything that will break
a person's fast. How many things break a
person's fast?
Six things. Number one and two,
eating or drinking intentionally. Number
three,
inducing oneself to vomit. number four
and five
it's for women
ministration or postpartum and number
six
number six
huh intercourse correct
okay
so let's do a couple of couple Couple
of checks here. So based on that, a
suppository, does it break your fast?
No. An IV drip?
Yes. What about a vitamin shot? No. What
about insulin?
No. What about rabies vaccine?
No. What about a nicotine patch?
[Arabic recitation]
Nicotine patch. Guy's a hardcore smoker
and he gets grumpy when he doesn't have
his nicotine.
So, he puts on a nicotine patch. Does it
break his fast? Yes. What's your
evidence for that?
Now, you got to name one of those six
things and then explain how it fits into
those six things.
Does it nourish the body? Nicotine
nourishes the body. Holy moly. I didn't
know that.
[Arabic recitation]
Huh?
does not break your fast.
Shik, nicotine patch. Yes, nicotine
patch does not break your fast.
Do we Do we advise it? People walking
around with nicotine patches on.
Absolutely not. But it does not break
your fast. In order for us to invalidate
something that Allah has built, we have
to
invalidate it with something that Allah
has deemed it invalidating.
Okay. What about nasal spray? Does it
break your fast? Yes. Okay. What about
an inhaler for asthma? Does it break
your fast?
No, it does not. What about smoking?
Does it break your fast?
[Arabic recitation]
much is a saw?
many's dismay. Yeah.
Okay. How much is a saw? A saw is a is a
measurement. How much is it?
[Arabic recitation]
volume. So, a slop is four double-handed
scoops. Not giant hands, not little tiny
hands, medium-sized hands. In today's
time, now what does that mean? In
today's time, yes, in today's time,
people continue to get what? Smaller
over time. You know, you know wisdom
teeth. Why do we have such a problem
with wisdom teeth?
Yeah. Well, our jaws are shrinking. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said in
Muslim that Allah created Adam 60
cubits. A cubit is is from the elbow to
the tip of the fingers. 60 cubits tall,
right? And then he says,
And people continue to get smaller
generation after generation,
shorter, smaller, right? So because of
that, our bodies are getting smaller. So
if you look at some relics of a
sword for instance from the time of the
or the time of the swords are huge.
You and I could not lift that let alone
fight with it. It's but that was
onehanded for them because they were
much bigger in their size. So people's
hands get smaller. Right? Assa for us in
our time if we were to to to weigh that
four of these that's going to come out
to about how many kilos?
Two and a half to three in there and
there. Okay. Well, you guys passed the
test.
My job is done.
All right.
Continuing
in where we left off yesterday
with respect to the subchapters.
And by the way, if anyone has a question
as we're going, you just raise your
hand, ask the question as we go along.
Hopefully, we'll have maybe a dedicated
question and answer session towards
the end of Ramadan. But
as we're going if you have any question
regarding the topic then feel free to
ask. So we are discussing some of the
sun some of the preferred
things for a person who is fasting and
some of the etiquets of fasting. The
author says,
"Another etiquette of fasting
is that a person be as quick to good
deeds and as generous in giving
as he can be and to study the Quran, the
prime focus of Ramadan.
Why Ramadan gets its virtue is because
it is the month in which what? The Quran
was revealed. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
Ramadan.
Notice notice how interesting this verse
is. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. When we
say Ramadan, what is the thing that most
prominently comes to mind with respect
to Ramadan?
Usually, it's fasting, right? And that's
what you would expect Allah to define or
describe the month as, but he doesn't.
He doesn't describe the month as the
month of fasting. He describes the month
as the month of the Quran. Not everybody
is fasting during the Ramadan, but
everybody should be focused as much as
possible on the Quran. Focused as much
as possible on the Quran. You know in
our society today usually in movies
or TV shows or on social media people
will show that you know they were
they were they were bad and they were
doing bad things and then they turned
their life around. And how did they turn
their life around? Well, now they go to
the gym every day and they work out and
they got slim. They lost a bunch of
weight and they got really strong and
they got, you know, their tennis shoes
on and their 7% body fat and right. But
nobody speaks about the or very rarely
do people speak about wisdom, knowledge,
the mind. A person wants to turn his
life around, memorize the Quran. It's
it's not beyond your reach. It is not
beyond your reach.
If a person were to memorize one verse
every day, just one,
one verse every day, in 10 years they
would be a complete half of of the
Quran. They will have memorize the
entirety of the Quran.
If a person were to dedicate half an
hour every night, half an hour, the
amount of time it takes to watch the
evening news before they go to bed.
Within a month, they will be able to
read the Quran. Within a year, they will
be able to read the Quran properly and
well. Within two years, they will be
getting up there in in excellent
territory. Right? These things are not
beyond our reach and the Quran has never
been more ubiquitous than it is today.
It is time for us to have the mus
everywhere we go. If you haven't changed
anything about yourself in the this
month of Ramadan, make the only thing
that you change is that the Quran is
more prominently fixed in your life.
Morning, evening, nighttime. The Quran
is the center thrust of the month of
Ramadan and it's really a preparation
for the sacred months that are just
around the corner.
Ramadan
Iban Abbass narrates this narration is
in Bkari Muslim. He said that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam was the
most
he was the most excellent of people
in good in righteousness in doing good
deeds. He was the most excellent
in righteousness
and he was at his height the height of
his excellence during the month of
Ramadan. Why during Ramadan? Ib Abb says
when Gibl would come and meet with him
every night and they would review the
Quran and revise the Quran. So every
year for the 23 years of his prophethood
in the month of Ramadan, Giblis would
would descend each night of Ramadan.
And this is one of the reasons not the
only but one of the reasons that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam didn't pray
most of the time in J. One of those
reasons is because he was busy with
Gibl. They would have what is called a
in which Gabriel would listen. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam would
recite to him all that has been revealed
up until that point. If there were any
amendments, any changes that were to be
made, they would be made during that
time. In the last year of his life,
sallallah.aii wasallam he and this is in
the ninth year after Hijra, he reviewed
the Quran with Girrel twice. So usually
each night until they would finish, but
the last year he reviewed it twice with
Giri. And this is what is referred to by
the scholars as
the final revision or the final
exhibition of the Quran. And that is
that the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam recited to Gibl. Gi would
listen if there were any abrogations,
the arrangement of verses, the
arrangement of the chapters. And this is
why the Quran is is arranged in the
order that it is today in the mus in the
correct opinion that was articulated to
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam in that
final year. So, Gibl told him these 114
chapters. Well, they were actually about
113 in Ramadan because
was revealed a couple months later and a
few verses here and there. But
essentially, these are the order of the
chapters. This is the final order. This
is the order in which the chapters are
to be revealed to be set. And so the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam recited
to him this the entirety of the Quran in
that year two times and it was cemented
and solidified at that point. Now the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
then spent the remaining four months or
roughly five months of his life after
that teaching the companions
what was finalized in that final display
of the Quran and that final revision
of the Quran in which these are the
order of the chapters these are the
order of the verses this is right and so
this is called
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
noticeably more excellent during the
month of Ramadan after each night having
this session with Jirel it affected him
deeply on a very deep level and so he's
reciting the Quran every every single
day we mentioned before his
of his portion, his w that he would
recite each day. And he would recite the
entirety of the Quran in how many days?
Seven days, right? So every seven days
he would have recited the entirety of
the Quran. He would recite first
three on the first day, the first three
chapters, then the next day the the
next five chapters and then after that
the next seven chapters and then the
next nine chapters and then the next 11
chapters and then the next 13 chapters
and then the remainder of the Quran
every single week.
But in spite of that, during the month
of Ramadan, when he would revise the
Quran with
and review the Quran with Gibl, in
those sessions, the companions noticed a
a noticeable
a noticeable increase in his
excellence, his excellence in everything
because the Quran had a deep impact. act
on him. And so the Quran, I mean, it's
the only book in the whole world
that gets better the more you read it.
It gets better to you the more you read
it. Any other book written by a human
being, once you have digested it
completely and properly, unless it is a
derivative of the Quran and Sunnah, it
will get old. Right? human being
naturally will will will have learned
all there is to learn from that and move
on except for the Quran.
The Quran every time you go through it
again and read it again it presents the
reader with a new set of challenges and
an entirely new path every single time.
Every single time. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam would
noticeably become more excellent during
the month of Ramadan. And Ib Abbass
tells us as a result of his review of
the Quran with Jirel. To finish the
narration, he says,
[Silence]
and sobb Abbas says that Girel
would meet the prophet sallallah alaii
wasallam on each of the nights of
Ramadan until the month was over. And
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam would recite to Jirel whatever
he had been taught thus far of the
Quran. And so when Jirel would meet the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam, we
would notice that he would become more
excellent and more swift to excellence
as a result of those meetings than a
strong gust of wind.
Just a reminder of the Quran competition
this evening inshallah.
It will start at 3 and it will end at
6:00.
Make sure that you either enroll
yourself or your children. It's going to
be very good inshallah tala. Also, the
schedule for tonight, , just some
slight changes are actually going to be
made to, , the 27th night, but it will
be a little longer. Look out for that on
the WhatsApp announcements.